[Música]
boa tarde a todos
infelizmente com muitos nós sabemos os
empreendedores sociais têm muito maior
dificuldade no acesso ao financiamento
do curso empreendedores considerados
tradicionais para percebermos a causa
desse problema talvez tenhamos coalhar
pra que o que acontece com os credores
toquem no gelo um ator bastante famosos
ficou intrigado com o seguinte factos
porque que a maioria dos credores na
opinião das seleções nacionais dos
estados unidos e do canadá
nasceram quase todos os primeiros meses
do ano janeiro sofreu mais foi
investigar e procurou a questão é quando
os 98 anos são divididos em duas equipas
as equipes de alto rendimento ou as
equipas do rendimento normal e os pêlos
etários são definidos de acordo com o
calendário do ano
no mesmo escalão podemos ter um jovem
que é 11 anos mais velho do que o jovem
faz muita diferença nesta idade
vocês conseguem imaginar qual dos dois
jovens é provavelmente é mais alto mais
forte a melhor estrutura física o jovem
já nã e é com base nesse critério que os
jovens integram as equipas dalfre
alimentos equipes recebem mais horas
trazendo mais três por semana melhores
treinadores melhor acompanhamento e o
que acontece
eventualmente esses jovens torna-se
mesmo melhores jogadores do hóquei no
gelo o que acontece é um exemplo
clássico de construção um facto verdade
a postura errada nós criamos milhões de
29 no gelo com base no pressuposto de
que a estrutura física é variável mais
importante acontece exatamente a mesma
coisa em relação aos empreendedores
sociais só que estamos a falar da
estrutura física estamos a falar
e tradicionalmente nós acreditamos que
os empreendedores tecnológicos e
comerciais são mais sustentáveis geram
maiores retornos e por isso tenham
acesso mais facilitado ao financiamento
dos empreendedores sociais e esta
situação tem vindo a contaminar e
condicionar o aparecimento de novas
soluções para problemas sociais antigos
a minha grande paixão é juntar o rigor
do mundo financeiro com o coração do do
setor social
mas para isso é preciso provar que nós
temos em investir na solução dos
problemas e obter simultaneamente
impacto e retorno financeira e sim vai
trazer uma mudança drástica e
basicamente o que eu gostava que
acontecesse é conseguir nos livrar os
empreendedores independentes e redes
sociais comerciais ou tecnológicas
surpreendido por um lado temos a sorte
de ter empreendedores sociais que todos
os dias trabalham arduamente para
resolver os problemas da nossa sociedade
o problema às vezes tem um custo
econômico eo vanice
o custo do ministério da justiça tem
vaga incidência criminal o custo para a
segurança social do desemprego jovem do
isolamento social de doses nós queremos
que esses empreendedores nos novos
problemas super complexo e faça um bom
trabalho
sem ela não existe uma moeda sem ovos
então pra isso nós precisamos fazer
novas perguntas
não conseguimos obter novas respostas
com as perguntas que fazemos sempre e
temos que inovar nas formas
financiamento e uma dessas inovações é o
título de impacto social é sair daí que
vai partilhar convosco hoje o título de
impacto social é uma forma de
financiamento quanto quanto maior for o
impacto social melhor será o desempenho
finança do projeto existe uma palavra
chave no título impacto social que é
orientação para resultados e resultado
diferente de atividades há indicadores
de atividades
uma coisa eu falar em número de horas de
formação
o número de sessões de formação número
de fumantes outra coisa eu falar
enquanto as pessoas é que integrarão o
mercado de trabalho como resultado de
uma certa são formação é esse resultado
vai provocar mudança social é isso
resultado vai fazer o setor público
gastar menos dinheiro é esse resultado
que nos deve importar mas como funciona
a estrutura impacto social
tudo começa com um problema que afeta
uma determinada população e tem um custo
directo o setor público
do outro lado temos uma mais
organizações sociais que têm um modelo
inovador para resolver esse mesmo
problema
juntamos um ou mais investidores sociais
esta parceria e temos o título de
impacto social o instituto social
assegura o financiamento ou a partida do
projeto a médio prazo digamos de dores
há cinco anos a organização social opera
durante esse período e no final os
resultados como falar pouco forem
alcançados o setor público sabe que vai
conseguir alcançar algumas poupanças e
peguem parte dessas poupanças que
utiliza para devolver ao investidor
social com ou sem retorno pendendo dos
casos se os resultados não forem
alcançados o setor com o youtube não
copa loc não paga mas vamos ver como é
que isso funciona num exemplo muito
concreto
a equipa do laboratório de investimento
social da qual faz parte há uns meses
antes janeiro 2015 foi falar com a
câmara municipal luiz me perguntou quais
é que são os principais problemas da
nossa cidade
e aí é que vocês querem inovar muitas
áreas ficarmos na educação e no uma
temática específica que em 1 vaga taxa
de retenção escolar juntos em algumas
escolas públicas lisboa no ensino
primário que nós temos noção é algumas
destas escolas uma em cada cinco
crianças chuva no 3º ano tem sete anos
de idade pois com o suspeito até que
esse problema custa e os números
oficiais dizem que um aluno custa em
média de três mil euros por ano
ora além do custo social de não
acompanhar os colegas ficarem city não
progredirem existem com este nome por
cada link chimba vai estar três mil
euros a mais do que supostamente deveria
tivemos que encontrar uma solução
inovadora que não tenha se está lá e é
aí que aparece o ensino da programação
informática e de time foi perfeito por
cada vez mais nós falamos em passar de
utilizadores de tecnologia para criar
novas tecnologia eo melhor altura para
aprender isso não acontecer - sete anos
de idade e é assim que nasce o primeiro
tipo de impacto social em portugal
a academia de kobe júnior que pretende
testar se o ensino de programação
informática tem um efeito positivo no
desempenho escolar
logo extinto - chumbos ao final do ano
permitindo ao setor público alcançaram
seus objetivos e não ter tantos custos
diários problemas sociais
o investidor a fundação calouste
gulbenkian e é financiar o projeto
durante dois anos a caminho do ódio que
têm ficado a trabalhar com os alunos no
final do projecto desta noite pois
saberemos se os alunos receberam as
aulas do programa são a informática tem
ou não um desempenho escolar a
portuguesa matemática 10 por cento
superior
um grupo de controle que não recebeu
essas aulas até mesmo de boa como disso
apenas paga se os resultados forem
alcançados na verdade este é um modelo
todos ganham porque a carne em pó óleo
açúcar se no seu trabalho a trabalhar
com os alunos primeiro quer que funciona
eo que não funciona é emprestar a
absorver o seu tempo na procura dos
próximos meses de financiamento como já
foi aqui falar
o setor público por pode ditar a
inovação sem qualquer risco se as coisas
não funcionaram eo instituto social a
fundação carlos que vem é porque desta
vez pode avaliar o impacto autor em
financiar a área e se eles continuarem
ia ver o seu dinheiro pode investir e
vai aumentar o financiamento
para financiar a inovação social
ora existem cerca de 50 tipos de impacto
social em todo mundo um deus em portugal
com uma câmera escrever e centenas em
fase de desenvolvimento
e se nós pensarmos a aplicação pode ser
variada podemos aplicar na área da
educação justiça saúde e proteção social
emprego e na verdade é que o título de
impacto social traz é uma coisa muito
importante que é um modelo de negócio
para os empreendedores sociais e um
modelo de geração de receitas das
populações com que os empreendedores
sociais trabalham e idosos em situação
de isolamento social pessoa sempre as
pessoas não podem pagar por serviço
recebem é tão sutil utilizador do
serviço não é o pagador
nós temos que encontrar quem beneficia
economicamente nós produzirmos o
problema é que nós fizermos isso nós
vamos trazer mais financiamento para
empreendedores sociais e vamos colocá
los ao mesmo nível dos jogadores dop
nasceram os primeiros meses do ano
enquanto isso financeiramente é muito
bonito e funciona mas para mim a
verdadeira inovação é social por 3 2
em primeiro lugar porque incentiva
exatamente essa inovação
não me interessa serviço tenha gostado
daquilo que interessa é o resultado em
si e está à margem de manobra às
organizações sociais para testar em
elevar em irem constantemente ao
encontro das necessidades dos seus
poluentes como os investidores têm
dinheiro em risco e esse risco pode ser
impugnado
se os resultados forem alcançados vou
ter todos os incentivos para trabalharem
com as organizações no terreno e
aprender a aprender a enviar alimentos e
de se andar de um exemplo quando
pensámos academia decod dinha achávamos
que eram precisos temos dois professores
em sala ambos agora a matéria
falámos com os alunos fazemos análises
dados etc
percebemos do desempenho estava a correr
tão bem como queríamos
ajustado e que estamos um novo deu em
que um professor dava aula e outro
professor que acompanhava os alunos com
maior dificuldade nas semanas que se
seguiram o desempenho geral das turmas
evoluiu significativamente ou então
quando percebemos nos alunos de escolas
e zonas mais desfavorecidas por não
terem se assim equipamento em formato em
casa são ateus durante o período escolar
evolua e mais acentuadamente nos também
são mateus que depois das férias do
verão ó das férias do natal estão num
ponto de partida mais atrasado e isso
permite-nos aprender sobre o que
funciona eo que não funciona e entra sai
por quando nós aprendemos tomamos
decisões mais informadas ea câmara
municipal de lisboa se um dia quiser
alargar a todas as escolas podem fazê lo
sabendo que terão impacto que deseja
evitar desperdiçar recursos financeiros
é algo que não funciona e aí o tipo de
impacto social é uma excelente
ferramenta para informar política
pública e coloca os empreendedores
sociais no centro da solução
o tema 2 vemos vindo a falar é a origem
é o início das coisas que eu acho muito
importante nunca esqueçamos que no
início não origem do setor financeiro
sua missão é contribuir para o
desenvolvimento econômico e social das
nossas sociedades e pra mim o tipo de
impacto social é o início dos dez as
origens do setor financeiro
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]